Dame Kristin.
Are we not having an interview?
No, it's just, we're having a chat.
The way we do.
Like we do.
Ladies and Gentlemen, Kristin Scott Thomas.
Here we are, working again.
You alone?
We go way back, don't we?
Oh, we do. We do.
Slow Horses is not casinos, champagne, and Aston Martins.
It's such the other side of James Bond, isn't it?
No, totally. Behind-the-mirror kind of James Bond isn't it.
It's the sort of stuff that you'd rather not look at.
Come see this!
Hostage.
What's it got to do with you?
Whatever's going on will be a job for the real agents.
It really has tongue in his cheek.
Personnellement, as the French would say, I really enjoy.
As the French would say.
What are you looking for?
He hasn't told me yet what I'm looking for.
Slough House is filthy!
You end up at Slow House and it's
a disgusting place, I mean…
It's interesting, you said, "Slow House."
Did I say Slow House?
Slough House!
But it is slow house too, isn't it? It's "Slow House".
Or we can sit here and watch the slow horses,
walk in one by one and accept
a job back here at the park,
while you fester in the basement.
If you don't take this too personally.
Brace.
You're very good at playing a tough…
Tough cookie?
Yeah.
I don't know where I get it from.
I don't know.
I've never seen anyone like
Jackson Lamb on my television before.
No.
Anyone with me tonight is fireproof.
God, you really care about them, don't you?
Nah, I think they're a bunch of absolute losers.
But they're my losers.
The Taverner, Lamb scenes are particularly juicy.
It always feels like a relief when you
know that you've got a scene with Gary.
I mean, they were great to act.
They bicker. They're almost like old lovers.
Like very old marriage.
What do you think you're playing at?
Do you think they enjoy it a bit?
I think they enjoy it a bit, and they've
learned to live with each other.
The dread is always sort of overtaken by this joy
that they get from this little, sort of, spark.
In three seconds, I could have a
dozen guns pointed at your head.
Yeah, but you won't do that.
It's fun to do!
You have actors you can play tennis with.
Yeah, you can rely on to surpise you and
send the ball back but in a surprising manner.
Absolutely.
That's really exciting, isn't it?
When I learned that Slow Horses
was coming together
I was thrilled.
I was thinking, oh that be great
to work with Kristin
Yeah. It's just so surprising
in its twists and turns.
And the characters.
Characters. Characters are great.
It's just so interesting.
You probably know how many people
have made it back from Slough House
to upstairs here at Regent's Park.
It's Saturday. Haven't you got other
peoples cats to steal?
None.
Thank you for joining us.
Who are you talking to?
I can't tell...
I'm talking to the audience.
Oh.
Our audience out there.